you get some political insights from the
Golden Globe carpet we cover politics
most of us don't ask me these questions
Governor Romney says he might run again
what do you think of that
we can run
but he can't hide
Lona romney says now he's thinking
running what do you think of that
everybody has the right to run this is
America you've worked in politics and
now you weren't right about politics
what are you looking for in a president
in her next president 2016 someone who's
able to go to Washington and
unlock the the logjam
get the timber moving down the river
what are we looking for in a president
I'm okay with what we got okay we have a
very good president right now we need a
better more informed smarter population
come on bring it on come it's come to
this I am so uncomfortable talking about
politics and yet I played a character
who is a lot of people would like to see
that sort of figure leading the country
maybe not
you know achieving office in the same
nefarious ways that Francis Underwood
does perhaps not by not killing anybody
we're losing as a better she has you or
Mitt Romney be the next president I
sense I think I got it whoever it is you
need with CJ Cregg yeah I miss being
like her in real life I wish that have
all the characters I played I wish I was
most like her in real life
let's get the deep thinkers in there
let's get the long ball I'm making any
sense you're speaking only in metaphors
I told you speaking that's how I ordered
my breakfast